[Music]
[Music]
in a minute i told you that already
all right late late uh where'd you grow
up where you from originally
from chicago moved out here in 86
moved to fig got introduced to this
pimping you know at a young age
fig is the whole stroke you know uh
grandma was a hoe
you know i mean uh my granddaddy was a
pimp
[ __ ] my older brother was a pimp i grew
up in tourism it's like
i had my first hole you know on the reel
i didn't even know she ain't even though
she was home for me it just
sort of happened you know i told her
y'all man you doing it for free go out
and you know
get money for it i mean we got to eat
you know straight up
and you were a whole you know man 13
yeah about 13. so you know how was your
challenge
my childhood yeah uh
i had to learn i learned fast you know i
mean i learned fast so i had a rough i
was beaten
you know i mean grew up around drugs
around holes and pimps all that you know
uh
so i learned how to you know i guess
finesse and talk to women
you know i became somewhat of a a slick
talker you know if it uh
you know a casanova what they would say
yeah yeah there's different styles of
them than europe yeah you got gorilla
you got finesse and you got sweet mac
i'm morphing that sweet mac pimp
yeah you think i'm saying i don't i'm
not really i don't really dig the
guerrilla tactics who showed you the the
game when you were young
you had somebody in the family uh i
ain't gonna lie
uh uh of uh when i first did it like i
said i had a young abroad
i was young 13 i introduced her to her
she was my girl at first and
you know i just she i guess she was
already uh
you know a lot of guys learned it
through a walk through the first garden
through a woman that's very common
that's what i'm saying basically like
she was already you know trained to go
so she
basically laced me with the game yeah
that's that's kind of and i took off
from right there
you know and uh as as we went on as i
became good at it you know and it's
stuck
once you get a taste of pimping you know
it's addictive it's very addictive
you know it's all on the bench you know
you know you don't really do nothing you
know you rest and dress
you know and you send you out you know
what what's the key
personality trait that you need to do
this basically you got to just be hard
on the whole you can't really have if
you have a
if you have any type of heart anything
they're going to eat you alive
yeah so it's all about the money it's
all about the money
and they get nothing you get it all you
know i mean
you basically or their manager you're
their bank here they're everything even
though they're gonna
trust you with it you know they bring
you 100 of the money
yes and you give them i give them
security
you know uh i make sure they eat make
sure they have anything that they
need i provide everything that they need
even what i'm saying when you say
security
how do you actually do that uh basically
uh
you know just cater to their knees you
know what i mean like every girl you
need somebody to talk to you gotta when
you're a pimp you gotta be their lover
you got to be there you know you got to
be there
their mentor you got to be there their
best friend you got to be there
they're the role model you got to be to
everything you got to be there you
they're they're rock you feel what i'm
saying you got to be there
you got to be there everything you got
to think for them you feel what i'm
saying
they can't think you feel them saying
they don't they don't they don't have to
think you don't want them to think
you got to think for them you feel i'm
saying so it's basically like
you just you got to know you know what i
mean when you do this
it can't be it got to be in you you feel
what i'm saying it can't be
you can't just wake up and do this
insane for everybody this lifestyle
right here everybody can say
they do this but you can't do this
unless you are really
about this you know pimping is a
lifestyle man it's a way of life you
know
it's beautiful you know i mean it's
beautiful i love it i
lied to you i love it how many girls you
got three deep no sleep
10 toes to the concrete you know
fig sapoda fig i mean i'm
i go back and forth sometime to the bay
you know i mean i'll be everywhere man
i get it in you know if one of your
girls gets in trouble with one of the
johns
ah she know what to do i mean does she
have her phone on so you can hear what's
going on or did she call you or was she
yeah she's going to call me
when she knows to call me that's when
she you know me but you know i'll bail
her out
it's a procedure she knows not to say
anything you know it's a procedure you
know
you know everything will be yummy she
knows what to do and what not to do
yeah and you have sex with your girls
they gotta earn that
you know yeah my dick ain't for free
it's a fifa [ __ ] with me you know you
know no
you know you've been in love before
love is for the week love of hell i mean
it's for the week
you know i mean i have before everybody
has once upon a time been in love but
i don't you know it's been so long where
i don't even
dwell on it you feel me i just i focus
on this pimping man
i'm trying to i'm trying to get it i'm
trying to pull the escalator the [ __ ]
sweaty ass man
that's just what it is
[Music]
and how do you handle girl she gets out
of line or starts she got out of line
you know you know
hey she could beat her feet you know
that's how it is
if they got a lot he knows different
ways you know i mean there's different
ways to punish them
you take all they [ __ ] you know you can
make them get outside [ __ ] negative
standing in the corner
you feel them saying different various
little you know i mean this [ __ ] like
that you know
yeah you know i make them put them on
time out you know different little stuff
like that
yeah the game has changed a lot the game
has changed a lot man it's it's a lot of
suckers in the game it's a lot of people
you know tainting the game you think i'm
saying there's not a lot of thoroughbred
pimps out here in this game anymore
you know what i mean so it's it's kind
of hard you gotta
you know weed out the the fake and the
frogs yeah
do you have a gang past were you in a
gang before this
or are you currently no i'm i'm all
pimping man yeah
sometimes they overlap them yeah
sometimes they do
and and sometimes they're your girls
doing things other than just sex for
money is there is there some kind of
like my girls already no they ain't
doing nothing for free
no but like you know sometimes they'll
relieve a a trick
of his jewelry or this oh yeah most
definitely if the opportunity sees fit
yeah
you know it's times where they do it but
i prefer not to because i want to keep
the business going you know
it's it's a business you know you don't
want to you know i mean [ __ ] where you
stay you know
burn your bridges but you know it
happens it happens you have
different you know situations where it
occurs but
for the most part you know
so what do you look for in a girl what
kind of personality traits uh
she got to be a good her down just
thoroughbred
holding some mo you know i mean just she
just got to just
be just a nasty just go get it whole you
know just don't care
just all she want to do is just please
me you feel what i'm saying just go get
the money
and bring it back to daddy you know man
that's just it that's what i look for
i look for complete submission you know
i mean
complete submission you know no
questions asked no
low lip you know straight up so we can
get it
have you had girls that just aren't cut
out for this kind of work you have those
you had those those the ones you don't
want because those are ones that
get you you know pimping and pandering
cases so you don't really want to force
anybody to do anything you you know i
mean you present it to them and try to
see
because you you know i mean basically
turn them out if they don't want to do
it you don't force anything on them but
i don't
you know man i could try to convince you
and plant the seed
you know and see if it flourishes but if
it doesn't
manifest that's you know you've been
arrested before yeah i've been arrested
before
i've been arrested assault i mean stuff
like that
got two pimping and pandering cases oh
yeah yeah
so do you think do you think that the
the reason that these girls will be
interested in a relationship like
the one the the life that they have
which is
you know guys who abuse them or
disrespect them or just use them
basically and then
working with a pimp who kind of takes
advantage of their
you know takes their money sometimes
treats them badly
it's it's a duplicate almost of their
childhood relationship they may have had
with their father right
they're missing i guess they missing
that it probably does you know i'm not
i don't really you know i just look at
like this
i just i'm good at what i do you
understand me so i just try to be
the best
i'm gonna say this the best the best
pimple or
or the best dad or the best dad i know
cause i'm dad
i mean that's what they call me i'm dad
you know i mean so i'm the best dad
possible i know you feel what i'm saying
my wholes love me
what i'm saying love me they cheer they
cater to me they
they worship me man you know me and i'm
a god you know
what are the me what if the roles were
flipped and you were doing you were
having sex for money
and the girl was keeping all your money
would you ever go for that
no but you expect the girls to do that
for you
hey it's the game it's the game you
can't knock the game man it's just
it's gonna always be it goes back to
biblical days man you know this game
ain't gonna never cease to be here man
pimping the horn is the best thing going
believe that you know it never changed
it's very profitable
you know it's profitable man there's
money in this man you know it's a
lifestyle like i say
everybody can't do this how old are you
i'm 38 38 so you've been doing it a
while been doing it
what was the craziest thing you've seen
in your years of doing this
yeah you've seen some crazy stuff i'm
sure yeah i've seen
i've seen a whole slice of her pimp you
know man seeing her slice his ear off
you know i mean for [ __ ] with another
broad you know i mean on the blade
you know man so i've seen that before
that was outrageous
he she was totally out of pocket you
know but uh
you know that's his pimping and mackin
minds is intact man
so long as my peas is intact i'm good
you know it's all about your peas man
it's it's a it's a doggy dog subculture
here isn't it
exactly everybody's looking out for
themselves the girls the guys the the
tricks the
exactly but i'm gonna tell you one thing
you know as long as you see it's about
your game too man
as long as you can implant you know that
picture in their head
you know me and you can you can implant
that
that picture that beautiful you know i'm
saying
you know uh whatever
reality or fantasy that they may want
you know i mean long as you can
fulfill that whatever dream that they
want whatever you gotta you gotta
basically pinpoint whatever they want
whatever fantasy that they want and you
just play on it you know what i mean
you exploit it you feel what i'm saying
it's it's it's kind of like mind control
right
exactly euphemism
master manipulation basically you know i
mean so
yeah yeah man it is what it is what's
the most important lesson you've learned
in your years
doing this to be observant you know i
mean to be
observant and also basically to humble
yourself more
you know i mean pay attention to
everything everything
because the smallest thing may count you
think i'm saying
yeah is there a quota for your girls
every night
yeah i need 1200 out of this girl every
night
you know man at least 1200 on a bad
night at least eight
you know but i never need 12. they don't
come back until now they can't come back
until yeah
on the real i need i need at least at
the least if it's bad i want eight
you're gonna get out there and get it we
got a quarter yeah i mean it's a quarter
to keep y'all you know i mean you
understand that it's quarter this is a
business
you know it shouldn't be no problem for
my girls to get 1200
you know me real talk especially with
the places i take them to
you what i'm saying where you're like
casinos and
some of them have you know do internet
you know stuff like that most of them do
they do that a lot of their dates like
that but i'll take them supposedly
so so do you get along with the other
pimps yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean i don't
know i mean i'm a pimp man i'm a macaron
all that you know i'm yummy yeah you
mess with
you guys all like yeah strawberries we
we players man well
y'all mean all that yo i mean we i mean
we got time for all that is to the bag
man
ain't got time for all that you know
frivolous you know
we'll get ugly though y'all man don't
get it twisted it will get ugly though
yeah i mean but it's it's it's cool man
i mean
you just get to the you know i mean just
get to the back man that's
your dick you you feel me you have kids
i got a 16 year old son man you stinking
ass fat
nasty [ __ ] [ __ ] maggot [ __ ]
you know man yeah are you raising him
nah nah he winner he with her
he with her man so
your girls are work where you say what
yeah you work the internet you work
they work the internet yeah they work
back page all stuff like that
uh what's that uh only fans only fans
only fans uh you know they could do
stuff on take top now
yeah you could do certain little stuff
on tick tock you know you can't actually
you know what i mean
you do certain little stuff on there
they're on the street as well
yeah at night time though at night time
yeah in the daytime they
they don't really daytime they do like
the internet and stuff and all like that
they do a lot of webcam shows and stuff
like that fetishes and everything like
that you get a lot of
freaky [ __ ] like new webcams
i'm serious bro that's a lot of money in
that
role playing dressing up uh interaction
like that
y'all mean little shows and [ __ ] it's
all type of little [ __ ] you know man
and if a girl wants out can she can she
get out
you know i mean [ __ ] they gonna find a
way to get out you know i mean if they
go get out i'm not for the force
like i said i'm you know that doesn't
really you feel what i'm saying i don't
force nobody to do nothing man
she gonna do what the [ __ ] she wanna do
you know i mean nine times
ten when they dealing with me you know
i'm with some pimping man
yeah i mean you just keep it clean you
ain't gonna be [ __ ] with me if you're
not
well me with no one you know i mean i'm
i'm letting that new you know and off
the triple
that's all i'm about i ain't with none
of that square [ __ ]
i mean real talk bro you know i mean i'm
just keeping it clean with you
you know all right late thank you so
much for sharing your story
i wish you the best of luck out there
man
thank you very much sorry thank you
peace
you